is about the money ever see on CBS this
morning
mountains of money Forbes magazine
reveals its annual list of billionaires
the magazine highlights the more than
2,200 billionaires around the world they
have a combined net worth of 9.1
trillion dollars at number 5 is
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg with an
estimated 70 1 billion dollars number 4
is luxury goods chief Bernard Arnault
and his family they're worth seventy two
billion an investor Warren Buffett is
third he's worth 84 billion Microsoft
co-founder Bill Gates drops one spot
from last year to number two with ninety
billion dollars and at number one for
the first time is Amazon founder and CEO
Jeff Bezos he is the first century
billionaire on the list with one hundred
and twelve billion dollars forbes
assistant managing editor Louisa Kroll
is here with more Ascenta billionaire
that's the first we're hearing and
seeing of wine locked in yes what is the
significance of Jeff Bezos and what he's
been able to accomplish with Amazon I
mean first of all it's just been such
huge gains you know we always talked
about will we ever see anybody that's
Ascenta billionaire of course people
joke and say are we ever gonna see a
trillionaire I'm hoping not in my
lifetime
but it's just the phenomenal gains and
the way that he's shaking up everything
that he's gone after Amazon started off
as an online bookseller it's now talking
about getting into credit cards it
bought a smartphone
doorbell company last week just when you
think they can't go bigger they go
bigger they go bigger and they keep
getting bigger they gain he was up over
39 billion dollars in 12 months last
year was another phenomenal year it was
the biggest one gain year since we've
been tracking world billionaires they're
gonna start buying planets next let me
ask you 67% of the billionaires on the
list are self-made that's fascinating to
me do they share some talent is there's
some reason is that higher than in the
past you know I always talk about kind
of like this X Factor you obviously have
to be incredibly driven a little bit
crazy a little bit passionate sometimes
you really have to come from hard-knock
life but you know have a hard-knock
story because you know the some of
these people were adopted some had
parents died they were working on
factory floors
I mean Oprah is a terrific example you
know she really had a lot it was
definitely self-made she was a yourself
in less than a minute tell us about the
the highest women on the list and why
you put Robert Smith on the cover okay
that's a lot to cover in one minute but
in their hearts there are a record
number of women there are 72 self-made
which is just really exciting because
that's always been a huge lag the
richest self-made woman is a woman named
Joanne Fey and she's one of these people
we were talking about her mom reportedly
died when she was younger she ended up
work in a factory aged 16 now she makes
the glass covers for a lot of our Robert
Smith on the cover
Robert Smith he has had such phenomenal
success in private equity he's one of
the most successful people on Wall
Street but you know it's great to
celebrate the successes of
african-americans and agree attack